[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well why don't we get started
um it's wonderful to see
um all the attendees tonight and um
i'm just gonna get started um tonight
we are very pleased to have jonathan
stern whom many
of you know um teaches in
the department of art history and
communication studies at mcgill
university
um he is the author of diminished
faculties of political phenomenology of
impairment
from which he'll be drawing tonight um
mp3 the meaning of a format
the audible past cultural origins of
sound reproduction
and numerous articles on media
technologies
and the politics of culture he is also
editor
of the sound studies reader and
co-editor of the participatory condition
in the digital age with co-author
mara mills he is working on tuning
time histories of sound and speed
hopefully we'll be able to
talk a bit about that in the q a and he
has a new project
cooking on artificial intelligence and
culture
so without further delay i'm going to
hand things over to jonathan
welcome okay uh can everybody hear me
okay
just making sure okay uh thank you vivek
uh i want to thank andrew too for
setting me up and remembering to ask
about my access needs that was a nice
touch
um you're gonna get a talk in three
parts today
originally i was gonna make you one long
movie and then i was gonna
chat with people in the chat window the
whole time
and it was gonna be great but it totally
didn't work
so there's a movie for 11 and a half
minutes at the end
the middle part is me doing talking
torso
for you and the first part is alas
torture by powerpoint or apple keynote
in this case
so here we are should be able to see
this so
i'm going to give you an overview of the
book we're going to do a deep dive
into one of the chapters and then we're
going to do
a sort of drive through of the third
chapter to mix
my metaphors i want to begin
um with a uh land acknowledgement and in
this case also a technological
acknowledgement sorry for my tweaking
here i'm just trying to get the
pictures out of the way of the text so
while zoom's the technical custodian
custodian of the platform on which were
gathered today
were no less occupants of the multiple
territories
on which were all physically located i
am speaking to you from the unseated
territory of jojage
now known as montreal the ghananyanka
aha sorry nation are the traditional
custodians of these lands and waters
although
learning the history of where you are is
an ongoing process
a good starting place might be the
website nativeland.ca
but wait there's more the platform we're
gathered on today
is provided by zoom a publicly traded
company valued at about a
117 billion dollars as of the end of
2020.
zum's headquarters are located on
a territory and when it comes to
sustainability communal living and
giving gifts to passengers by
the alone a have more to offer than
another corporation
the olani's horizontal society might
inspire different emergent models
of peer-to-peer networking in the
pandemic than we're enacting here on
zoom
so as we meet today let's reflect on the
unfinished work of restitution
justice and reparation
so i'm going to tell you a little bit
about the book
that i just finished copy edits on and
that's coming out december
2021 the title is diminished faculty is
a political phenomenology
of impairment a subtitle that is sure to
keep it out of airport
bookstores and i also like before i get
too far i can't actually see that many
people's
um that many people as i'm talking
but you should feel free to stretch to
look up
look down look around turn off your
video whatever's comfortable for you
as we're going through this talk so the
book is a weird book for me i mean i
guess all my books are weird in some way
but this one is also highly personal
in 2009 i
discovered that or rather my doctors
discovered that i had a very aggressive
case of papillary thyroid cancer
they might write recurrent laryngeal
nerve
that means that one of my vocal cords is
paralyzed
this one so instead of going like this
which is what they did before
2009 and what normal vocal cords do
now they work like this so it is harder
for me to talk
and to swallow i do get plastic surgery
every 18 months or so
on the paralyzed one to plump it up
you'll see a short video
clip of from one of those surgeries
later on
but of course this has profoundly
affected my voice
now that may or may not be audible to
you because
my vocal disability is not always an
audible disability in fact
sometimes when my voice is in the worst
condition it sounds the best
in a sort of like tom waits meets lauren
bacall after several packs of cigarettes
kind of thing um so
you know lots of friends said hey you've
published two books on sound you should
really write something about your voice
this is harder than it uh seems
um but this led me down a path i've been
reading and thinking with disability
studies for many years
and it sort of led me down the path of
uh
working on and thinking about this book
so um the chapters are as follows the
first one is really
an attempt to think about what it would
mean
to write about my voice which is to say
uh it's me trying to resettle my
accounts with phenomenology
in the audible past i was quite
dismissive of phenomenological
approaches to experience
but at the time i was also pretty
unaware of all the feminist
critical race and disability work in
phenomenology and since
the beginning of the 21st century
there's much much more
um and so that chapter is an attempt to
think like what is it
to do a phenomenology of a faculty when
you're not in full control of it
because most phenomenologies begin from
the presupposition that the subject uh
doing the phenomenologizing that's not a
word but
the subject doing the phenomenologizing
is in control
of the faculties and the experiences
that they're describing
um and so it is in some ways the most
ponderous chapter
uh because it's written in that sort of
ponderous phenomenological voice
but it's also got lots of good uh
details of uh awkward social
interactions
and uh it also begins with me waking up
on the surgical table
so there's that uh chapter two is meet
the dorka phone
this is the darker phone oh yeah i
forgot i have pictures um this is an
illustration for chapter one
uh done by uh lachlan jane my tumor was
7.5 centimeters one day we were sitting
on the porch trying to figure out
what what else is 77.5 centimeters
and so uh lachlan uh very
uh kindly helped helped me and us out
with it
uh and so that's in the book so chapter
two is about the dorka phone that's
gonna be what i talk about today so i
won't say much about it
right now except it's a personal voice
amplifier i have had to
oh and also it's dork with a d
not bork with a b because voip has this
thing where a certain consonants aren't
distinguishable from one another
so it's not pork when you think of bork
think of chihuahuas when you think of
dork think of my
personal portable speech amplifier and
this
picture which is at my desk a few
minutes ago
is um what i'm calling the auto dorka
phone which i'll talk about
uh midway through the talk but you can
see there's a microphone there
on uh like a radio arm there's a pair of
headphones just above my keyboard
and then there's a blue object on my
desk and i'm going to talk about those
a little bit uh later on chapter 3
is written uh so chapter one and chapter
two i really do talk about myself and
then
i just can't deal with it anymore so i
more or less stop
talking about myself chapter three is
written as an imaginary exhibition
uh we've even mapped it out for you so
you can see here
uh where the different exhibits and
rooms are
and the chapter is actually written as
the text of an audio guide
so even the detours through theory it
says like press star for more
information
on the uh um ideology of vocal ability
or for more history of the larynx or
something like that
so um it's also like very much a conceit
but that chapter is about trying to
think about
different configurations of voice
body and agency and i will show you some
things from it
i'll give you a little sample from the
last part of my talk
chapter four is about a normal
impairment which is hearing
impairment we and by
by we i really mean me and the people at
mit
i don't know everybody who's attending
the talk
but at least the people on my screen
live in a culture that's
mostly designed for people who are a
little bit hard of hearing
this is uh from a work called
constellations by the australian artist
marco fusionato
and it is designed to produce i think
120 decibels of sound
when you hit a wall with a baseball bat
and um it's not just
things like constellations that produce
this
like huge amount of sound obviously
concerts
sporting events things like that we
think about that but also airplanes
and those high-powered hand dryers in
tiled institutional bathrooms
all of those produce very high volumes
of sound which means
in those spaces it's better to be a
little hard of hearing
than to not be a little hard of hearing
and so in this chapter i really start
looking at what a normal impairment is
and what a sort of culturally preferred
impairment is and so instead of talking
in terms of hearing loss
or hearing damage i use sort of the
anthropological literature on body
modification and scarification
as my guide and so the chapter is called
audio scarification
and it's everything from loud noises to
the historical origins of earplugs
the final chapter is called there isn't
there are never enough spoons
uh it is named for an idea from the
writer christina
mizeron miserandino who
coined the spoon theory uh which is a
way of sort of quantifying one's own
fatigue so the chapter begins as a sort
of unpacking of this idea of fatigue as
depletion
most concepts of fatigue are concepts of
a subject depleted of energy
and it ends with an attempt at a
non-depletionist account of
fatigue and this is interesting and
important because in disability theory
there are so many critiques of writing
about
impairment and disability as something
that is less than
uh that which is that which is
non-impaired or non-disabled
but when we get to fatigue even in the
disability literature it is treated
mostly as an absence
or a depletion uh the final chapter or
the conclusion then
is an instruction manual for using
impairment theory
it's illustrated by the artist darshan
hewitt this is one of her
illustrations uh and um
i guess that's all i'll say about it no
one ever reads the instruction manual
but you might want to read this one
okay that is
my powerpoint i'm going to stop sharing
now
now you will see my rather large
head now we're going to do a deep dive
into chapter 2 which is entitled meet
the dork of phone
so this is a darker phone
it's basically a transistor radio with
no radio
attached to a small wearable microphone
that lives inside a vinyl pouch
and you can't really see it here but it
has fake cow skin
uh embossing it can be hung around my
neck
its real name is the spokeman personal
voice amplifier
other devices can be clipped to a belt
or built in the belts themselves or can
be laid out on the table
i own two spokemen's or do you call them
spokesmen
no that's two dork of phones each of
which cost me about three hundred
dollars
total though it seems prices have
dropped since i purchased the last one
in 2012.
i've had both my units repaired more
than once
and they're clearly not designed for the
abuse i inflict on them
i throw them around accidentally but i
do it
uh they live in backpacks they travel
all over the world with me
they've been operated at high altitude
and yet they're also surprisingly hearty
um
and in some ways even though part of me
says
this is just a transistor without a
radio without a radio that i could pick
up for five bucks
at the thrift store when i look inside
is actually a marvel of engineering
of miniaturization and of durability
now the name spokeman is either a misuse
of spokesman
like a mistranslation or more likely an
unsuccessful riff on walkman
which it must be noted was not named
listen man or listen man
probably for good reason the spokeman is
one example in a genre of voice
amplifiers
a genre without a shared name or a
defining brand like kleenex or xerox
but whose names all point to this weird
gray area
of voice and techne that it occupies
speech amplifier
voice amplifier personal public address
system
personal voice amplifier chatter vox
amplivox sound pocket xavox
zowatik voice buddy sound buddy
zygo but unlike the walkman they don't
signify mastery or
coolness they represent the social
oddity of personal voice amplification
itself
in one way it shouldn't be odd at all
voices are amplified all the time
and just think of us now doing our
academic business
meeting as we are gathering as we are
over zoom
everyone is using microphones and
speakers in fact
my dork iphone right now is turned off
i'll turn it on for a second
you can hear it amplifies my voice a bit
which reduces my vocal strain i never
use my darker phone
on zoom i'll have things to say about
zoom a little bit later
um so this is purely uh for the benefit
of this talk
uh in real life i haven't had an
occasion to use this
since before march 2020
but still i wrote about the darker film
so let me tell you about it
public address systems microphones
speakers
are common objects all over the world
and in many places it's a daily
experience to be serenaded
by a host of voices meant to refer to
distant or absent bodies
contemporary audio culture in most of
the world now is speaker culture
and here speaker refers to the technical
devices not
the people now even though my dorka
phone is technically the same thing as a
pa system
just smaller it's socially set apart
its oddity is socially produced it is a
design object you might expect to
fall under the category of audio
wearables mp3 players
earbuds smartphones and now even boom
boxes thanks to lighter bad
batteries and other advances
but categorically it falls on the side
of
a prosthesis artificial limbs
insulin pumps crutches if they had to
if you have to experience the dorkophone
as a prosthetic
i wish they were more like eyeglasses
once a stigmatizing object
and now a fashion accessory
instead dorkaphones share a set of
cultural and technical problems with
hearing aids
and cochlear implants hearing aids
introduced issues of portability and
miniaturization in microelectronics
while generations of users have had to
negotiate their relationship
among social appearance stigma and their
own needs
and desires for the technology and mara
mills has written about this in jaipur
verdi's new book um hearing happiness
also deals with uh the history of
hearing aids and
deafness cures
so the dorica phone is a prosthesis it
is
an assistive technology and one of the
standard arguments in disability studies
most recently
and eloquently made by sarah hendren is
that assistive
in front of technology is actually a
redundant term
because all technologies are designed to
assist so what an assistive technology
does
it marks the person who is
visibly using it as in need of
assistance
in other words the technology itself is
in some ways disabling
socially even as it is assistive
processionally
when a space makes demands and people
have to make demands
back it marks them as different
irrespective of their self
concept so i can imagine myself as
impaired
as disabled or non-disabled
and the prosthesis does its semiotic
work on my body
in terms of the perceptions of others
hegel and his followers explained that
identification's
not just an individual choice the
politics and phenomenology
of disability have an irreducible
relationship
to the politics of recognition and
therefore also
to the politics of a prosthesis
the simple choice of where to position
the speaker on my body
raises the questions of under what
conditions
a ver person has a voice to speak with
and from where it truly comes
the darker phone speaker cannot be
positioned over the mouth
and yet the mouth is supposed to be the
visual and sonic point of origin
of the voice though even though
technically
mouse are just modulators in wearing a
darker phone suddenly my voice
is somewhere it's not supposed to be and
my mouth is
not doing something it's supposed to do
it thus creates a distance
between me and my voice even though
there's
already one and the mic and my on my
head in the box hanging from my neck
call attention to this distance
destabilizing
ideologies that naturalize voice and
speech
it performs a distance for others who
see and hear me
who are dealt then with a rich hand of
philosophical questions about voice
intention and embodiment which they can
either confront
or work to ignore
so this simple prohibition do not
hide your mouth with a prosthesis when
speaking
initiates one of the most demanding
conceptual exercises
in voice theory that is because
of this close visual coupling between
mouth
and voice which i'm going to call oral
voice
the oral voice is everywhere in writing
about voices and in vocal iconography
and while clearly sorry looking at the
wrong place
it begins from a normative voice and a
normative
mouth i can't imagine contemporary work
that engages with coloniality sexuality
gender race
uh or any other area from the standpoint
of a positionless writer
performing a kind of god trick in donna
haraway's term and yet
much writing about the voice outside of
voice studies
still treats the voice uh from a
position of seeing from nowhere and a
hearing
from them everywhere
the dorica phone's dorkiness is not an
accident
prosthetic fashion and by extension the
user's emotional relationship with the
device
has often been the last concern for
designers and there's this booming
literature now
on disability and design in addition to
the hindrance book
that i mentioned and the verdi book i
read i've i'm
mentioned uh amy hamray bess williamson
and grand palm have also written
excellent things um on disability in the
politics
of design the dork of phone
follows that sort of
prosthetic politics as vivian subchak
has written
the fluctuating line between the and my
prosthesis
makes her all sorts of give and take
around meaning in her case and she's
talking about a
uh an artificial leg she says their
significant figural movement
from mentonomy to synecdoche from thou
prosthetic viewed abstractly
to my prosthetic leaning up against the
wall
near my bed in the morning to my leg
which works with uh the other one and
enables me to walk
in my case the darker phone assimilates
into my voice in action
so let's follow subject's arrow
figuration
the voice is an impossible abstraction
my dork-a-phone charging on my desk
my voice what makes the dork-a-phone
noticeable and sometimes uncanny
is its proximity to the physical
generation of sound
in my diaphragm throat and mouth this is
its defining technocultural
feature it audibly invisibly marks my
vocal system
as a need of supplementation when it's
supposed to be self-sufficient
and that's my doorbell which i'm not
answering in the middle of a talk
um uh and it's worth
uh um pointing out that this uh
um idea of prosthesis is still getting a
lot of play in media theory right so
that meteor prosthetic
in inherently in some way um but that is
to metaphorize prosthesis and in
mcluhan's original
uh discussion of it it's quite he he
metaphorizes directly he says media
like our prosthetic or they amputate the
body but he's not actually talking about
actual
amputation or amputees so disability
becomes a
sort of ableist metaphor the imagination
the ableist imagination of what
amputation might be like
undergirds that theory and i think the
same might be said for prosthetic
theories of writing in derrida or
prosthetic theories of technology and
the hand
in stigler but that's a that's a
discussion
uh for the q a if that's something
you're interested in so i think it's
good to sort of cordon off this category
of the prosthetic as a particular kind
of technology
tied to a particular kind of political
situation
rather than as a sort of generalized
metaphor
for understanding media
so the dork of phone does this sort of
techno vocal
doubling if we're going to riff if we're
going to mention derrida we could call
it
dorco phone a leg and voice prosthesis
present themselves differently as
subjects we tend to adjust to them
differently and legs and voices
represent different things
but of course the metaphoric politics in
the metaphoric
process is related
so i'll give you one example an arrival
of one of our house parties in 2011
looked me up and down right after i
opened the door to greet him smiles
points and asks what the [ __ ] is that
i offered the shortest explanation i
could muster glasses for my vocal cords
cane for my voice works well too and
within minutes
we were talking like nothing was out of
the ordinary right so there's that sort
of shock
and then assimilation which is something
that rosemary garland thompson
has talked about uh with disability in
the gays
so once the social question the darker
film presents is answered
what the [ __ ] is that it retreats back
into my voice
it becomes part of me in the course of
social interaction
now i have more to say about dorka
phones and prosthesis
but i want to i want to talk to you a
little bit
uh from a section called of other
dorkophones which is named of course for
uh
foucaults of other spaces um
and i i've i've worked on some sort of
experimental alternatives but now i want
to talk about the setup
uh that came with zoom because it
actually it pertains to you even if you
don't
have a vocal impairment
my confinement during covet has led to a
voice amplification problem that's
slightly different
and it's related to hearing oneself
speak
when commentators reflect on zoom
fatigue they tend to reflect on
the problems of looking at other people
or even looking at yourself
all day but there's also a problem of
hearing
on a landline telephone the phone
receiver plays back a little bit of your
speech into your ear
this feedback mechanism is important for
people like me
who are trying to avoid vocal strain
put simply people tend to talk louder
when they don't hear their own voices
and it's while it's possible to unlearn
this behavior it's difficult
and i actually haven't successfully done
it um
and this is why when mobile phones were
first a thing there were
all these sort of commentary pieces and
cartoons about
people yelling into their phones mobile
phones don't have this feature because
it was
either injured out engineered out as a
non-necessity
or presented some kind of obstacle and
voice
over internet over over internet
protocol voip
also doesn't have this which means skype
zoom whatsapp
messenger teams and all the rest do
not feedback your voice into your ears
so while i have no practical use for my
dorka phone
right now speaking to you the only way
to get through many hours of video chats
for work
would be to construct an assembly of
technologies and techniques
for hearing myself speak i call this
assemblage the
auto dork of phone so that is the
microphone
the microphone arm and the headphones
and then the blue device on my desk that
i mentioned before
basically what happens is it plays back
my voice
into my headphones as it goes into the
computer
so i can hear myself speak and so i can
modulate
my voice actually achieving this was
somewhat difficult there's uh
some tech support jokes in the article
but i'm gonna are in the chapter but i'm
gonna leave leave this story there
so to wrap up the only adequate fear and
i should say to wrap up this section
before we move on to the movie which is
the last part of the talk
the only adequate theories of vocality
begin from a founding disunity
of people and voices and a founding
understanding of voice
that casts it in the plural there's a
growing body of scholarship that begins
from this premise
you know i time amanda weidman merrill
halper
kathy meisel to name some places you
could start your reading if you're
curious about this
for me and for anyone with an impaired
voice this is a personal
political and philosophical project
all at once people are at
all at best vocal operators
those operations happen in a world
suffused by the ideology of ability
which says that ability
is preferable to disability
they're also suffused with the ideology
of vocal ability
where i operate a voice as if it were
the carrier of my intent
as if it were my soul and will spilling
forward
out of my mouth with my breath what i
seek
from any dork of phone is a kind that's
perfect
what i seek from any darker phone is a
kind of instrumental relationship
a merger of subject and object where the
articulation of body
vocalization and device becomes just my
voice
in a moment of action as in any tool use
this instrument instrumentality requires
practice and work
like a musician who bonds with some
instruments but not others
my problem with other darker phones is
that i don't know if i can get
to this state of instrumentality
okay that is the
talking torso part of the talk now and
i'm gonna
i made a video for you and so this will
be the last
uh 11 minutes of the talk and it's a
little
like uh introduction to some of the
things you'll find
in the imaginary exhibition uh
of other localities
here we go
yes
oh my god
so i wanted to just share a few examples
from the imaginary exhibition
uh of the new vocalities that i thought
would benefit
from durational media her
durational presentation this first one
is nina ketchup durian's talking popcorn
as you can see it handily explains
itself
check out that microphone
there it is again
here
[Music]
so
my favorite thing about this piece
besides the just
incredible amount of labor uh and the
elaborate sort of
rude goldberg machine to set this up is
the degree to which
it shows that voice is a matter of
reception
and interpretation so one of the things
cachadorian did is actually
take those last words and
play them for and show them to
a cartographer a death duolla
psychoanalyst
sound theorist
and a bunch of other experts to get
their interpretations of it so
not only is it this wonderful sort of
dissolution of voice into signals and
perception it's also
um a sort of meditation on the
centrality
of interpreting when talking about what
a voice is
and how a voice works the other thing
i really like about the piece is that
microphone that mic is a sure sm57 which
in the performance world is like the
most ubiquitous vocal microphone on
earth
it is also the one
one of the ones most well designed to
take endless abuse
and so an sm57 is the perfect thing that
you want to expose to the heat
and grease of a popcorn popper uh
because it's a vocal mic not
for rarefied studio situations
but for everyday performance and perhaps
the kinds of
catastrophes that happen to technologies
often in bars
the second piece is uh
listening in a portrait of charles
gracer uh by the artist darren martin
and as you can see from the image here
it's actually a multi-modal work that's
meant to be projected in three different
places at once and then you're in a room
and the sound
sort of comes around you so it's even a
bit of a reduction to
for me to present it to you in this
two-dimensional film format
but here you have voice and listening
sort of
distributed in very interesting ways
right you have the text
you have all the sound modulation you
have human speech
you have interpretation tied to speech
and
you have signing as well
wow
well when i was teaching high school
i already had three young kids in the
house with my wife and me
and i needed money and i enjoyed driving
so i drove
tank trucks
and i was driving for richfield finally
and
one sunday i took the truck out
and i had to be back because there was a
school function attitude of the evening
this next piece by hodan yusuf is
an experiment in deaf music video so it
actually
has no soundtrack um and this was done
uh with a group of people sort of
organized by vero leduc at the
university of quebeco morial
yusuf is a deaf artist and performer and
you can see
it is very musical despite there's no
sound here signing takes the place
of vocality it takes a place of
um an audible voice on an audible
soundtrack
uh and produces both sort of the uh
expressive form as well as the
sort of narrative form of the video
to
[Music]
and the last piece i'll share with you
today is uh
from the artist aaron g it's called the
larynx series
so what she did was take a medical
photograph of a larynx
turn it into vector like graphics and
then lay them out
flat and the reason she did that is
because around the
edges of the larynx there was there were
lines that
in the vector graphics form looked sort
of like musical notation so she took it
really seriously and you can see here
she spreads out uh the lines around the
edge
she then writes musical notation
over for the voice over the uh
over over the vector graphics and then
that is eventually turned into a musical
score
which you are hearing performed
as i'm talking to you and there's uh
there's
one of the vocal parts that you're
hearing performed
so obviously there's much more in the
exhibition i just wanted to give you a
little taste of what you might encounter
there
hi and also show you ones that benefited
from
playback over time so speaking of time
i'm definitely at the end of my talk
here i want to thank you all for
sticking
around and listening and i really look
forward to discussing this with you
and again if you're interested in
anything i've talked about not only do i
recommend that you check out my book
when it comes out
but that you check out the writing of
the authors i've referenced throughout
this talk
thank you
[Music]
no
[Music]
i'm out of speaking and can you please
listen louder
[Music]
all right thank you so much um i'm gonna
open up
thanks to questions um
there we go yeah happy to discuss
anything
um so uh i'll be keeping an eye on the q
a
uh bar as well as um taking
taking questions from on screen um
whether you'd like to
use your hands or the hand symbols
i see tl wondering about the video lag
uh i don't know if everybody had that
that was not intentional that's just
the crapness of streaming well it was
perfect because it was the one where
there was also the audio was coming
through seamlessly
so it was this wonderful juxtaposition
of the two moments so
perfect this is all about rupturing the
audio visual contract
yeah well it did remind me a lot of old
eno looping stuff
as well so it caught my ear good um well
i'll start with a
question just picking up on on one
uh one thing that you mentioned in
passing and that is the
um the sort of more recent move
to uh in design
in terms of
applying new design principles to
[Music]
prostheses to different um
the different kinds of devices that are
used
by various different people and
i'm just curious to hear a little bit
more about that about
sort of both the the actual
design process and and the kind of
um i guess the the impetus behind it
who who is involved in um
in just designing new
new forms of prosthesis and
[Music]
sure well um this is part of a bigger
movement called participatory design
and the basic idea is that you shouldn't
design stuff for people without their
input
which sounds like incredibly obvious
but it is designed for disability has
not really been
a principle until pretty recently so
um uh so designers
in the last couple decades have started
working with people with disabilities
and also thinking more seriously about
um prostheses and
other technology assistive technologies
as design objects
whereas before they were generally
thought of more
in functional ways part of this might
also be like you know they were being
presented as medical technology
in the us they were being presented to
the insurance industry
uh for for coverage so you certainly
want them wouldn't want to look like
you're enjoying it
or having any fun with it like that's
always bad for
the protestant ethic of uh reimbursement
but um but yeah the idea
the idea behind it is simply the um
on one so for one uh you know
if you're designing something for
someone they ought to be involved
and two the design for disability really
pushes the edges of design and that's
really a central theme in in all four of
the design
books i mentioned two of them are sort
of history and two are much more
contemporary but what they all have in
common is showing the ways
the disability reveals aspects of design
that are limiting
not just for people with disabilities
but for everyone
and also pushes the edges of what's
possible in design thinking and design
theory so like the classic examples for
those of you that don't read in
disability studies
are things like the curb cut which um
activists uh in wheelchairs most notably
the rolling crips in in
berkeley had to fight for but of course
are useful
to people not just in wheelchairs but if
you've got a granny cart
coming from the supermarket or for that
matter of double bass with a wheel on it
uh or a rollerboard suitcase or pick
your
pick your example another would be
closed captioning which is a fight we're
having right now
um in terms of online media uh and zoom
and things like that
um closed captioning not
uh available it's seen as just a
minority interest but of course today
closed captioning i'm not that i've been
to any of these places in the last year
but
health clubs airports bars any places
where looking at you might not actually
want to listen to what's on the screen
but you might want to know
what's being said with closed captioning
for zoom there's actually an additional
sort of political dimension which is
that it's done by
otter.ai and this is something i'm
writing about with one of my students
otter um basically you know he
uses machine learning um to to uh
try to caption and it's it's better than
anything that i've seen that's come
before other than actual human beings
doing it and of course human beings will
always give you better captioning
and at least for the time being um
but otters user agreement's very
interesting because what they say is
well we don't own
your speech we don't own the content of
what you're what you say
but they do feature extraction they do
voice printing
right so in a way the minute you get
uploaded
into that world data are being generated
about you and you're being voice printed
so that's a great example of also
the conflict between um design for
disability
and the politics of access and
um sort of other kinds of capitalist
enterprises
that uh might be i mean there isn't a
good word for this in my disability
class we call it [ __ ] washing
like green washing where it's this uh uh
it's being presented as uh maura mills
calls it the assisted pretext or it's
being presented as useful
for uh people with disabilities but it
also has this other
economic or political function so those
are some of the things
about design and disability my dork of
phone is clearly not
an example of design uh for disability
however i have been working with an
artist
alexis immanuelof uh you can
go to her website luthery postmodern
um and she has been working on she does
uh these giant sort of
panel based speakers so instead of
having like
a magnet and a cone like a normal
speaker does it's all a single
board and so she's been building the
these based on wood panels we did one
experimental one
a few years back but the batteries were
too heavy but
advances in battery technology have
actually allowed the
creation of a much more uh a lighter and
more fashionable dorka phone that
working on trial when there's
an occasion to do it will you still call
it a dorkathon when it doesn't
[Music]
thanks for such a interesting talk it
was really cool um
i i really love the the point you made
about
um kind of rethinking phenomenology
and and sort of i don't know revisiting
that approach and
and then your your own writing and sort
of uh
yeah a more personal voice at points
point so i just i was just curious if
you had any other kind of meta
reflections on
on writing phenomenology in your own
experience i don't very
very open-ended but
thanks well i'm definitely not planning
to do it in everything i write for the
rest of my career
um i don't know it's really like
i you know part of me doesn't like
putting myself on i'm already putting
myself on display when i tell you what i
think about other people
it's worse when i'm telling you what i
think about something happening with
myself
but i think the grand con of
phenomenology
uh especially like the husserl
heidegger and even marilu ponte although
he's better and he's the one that the
feminists tend to go back to
um the grand con is that
you can you're in a position to
like abstract your subjectivity from
your senses
i mean the other thing i didn't get into
this in the talk but i spent a lot of
time in the book
thinking about impairment as a sort of
very normal though not universal
condition
um and the degree to which it affects
things
like the simple act of description right
so when scholars describe something and
you could think this ethnographically
you can think of it in literary
criticism
in film theory and historical musicology
in history and architecture and art
history like pick your discipline
in every case when an author gives a
description
we are to believe that the author is in
command of their faculties
now that's part of the academic game
right we're trying to convince each
other that we're smart
that's authorial ethos you want that at
the same time
analytically like if you're really
thinking seriously about
senses and faculties from a disability
perspective you cannot have that
assumption
and disability studies itself hasn't
fully reckoned with this
i mean there are writers who do this
really well uh allison
kaifer does this really good job in um
um uh feminist queer trip where she sort
of interrupts
her discourse to sort of say well
actually like even i can't live up to
this
intellectual ideal that i've set up
but i think it's a really good challenge
for theory and i also think it's a good
challenge
for theory in this moment where people
are trying to figure out
how to be positional but still
talk beyond themselves and not just
stand here and say like
you know as a white male in montreal
with these disabilities blah blah blah
like how do you
how do you and so it's a it's a question
of abstraction and also
a question of like the more concrete the
description is in a way
the more generalizable it could be
because you know the position it's
coming from
uh and so for me this whole book it was
very much especially the first three
chapters like and then the conclusion
very much and a little bit elsewhere an
experiment in writing
um and trying to write a little
differently i mean i think it probably
still sounds like me whatever that is
you know the
author function jonathan stern but i did
try
to write differently at times i'm having
fun with it obviously with all the dork
of phone
puns and stuff and that's sort of the
[ __ ] humor chapter
um i don't know i'm if i mentioned this
like originally i wanted the book to end
with a cat throwing up on me
but uh that but that ends the fatigue
chapter
uh and i couldn't figure out how to how
to
how to make that the end of the book and
have a conclusion so i had to let that
go
so there is some like humor and i try to
sort of self-deprecate but of course
it's with a wink and a nod because i
also want you to believe me
and like take what i'm saying seriously
so
i don't know it's definitely like a sort
of mid-career book in that way like
you know i i can't believe that they're
letting me do this kind of uh
writing but it it was a good experience
i don't know
uh i don't know what it's going to mean
for down the road like i
i finished it and i'm like okay i really
want to write about other people now i
don't want to keep writing about myself
um and i also think that's really
important right now because there's a
lot of other people and other things
that need writing about so i see there
are other questions so i will
hold my discourse um i'll go to kelly
and then
i'll take a question from the q a bar
and then back to nick
thank you for the talk um i was
interested
in the comment you mentioned kind of
from a media studies perspective
how you know your the voice is kind of
like your voice but
versus the voice the kind of the
mediated voice that goes through
[Music]
an object and then is still your voice
and how they kind of merge
sometimes and i guess i just i found
that whole
train of thought very interesting but i
didn't quite know how to
think about it and i was wondering if
you could kind of expand on
how you think about that for sure and i
actually do in the book i mean
one of the you know it's always tempting
to start a talk with a lot of
caveats by the way thank you for the
great question and thank you tl for the
great question and also thank you vivek
for the great question
i need to say thank you more obviously
um
it's always a temptation to give lots of
caveats but one of the things i
gave up was a little bit of conceptual
precision to try to be a little more
engaging in the setting so
this is the book might answer the
question or am i not
um okay so a couple basic things from
sound studies any sound always has
multiple causes
like we're used to thinking of like a
sound having one cause
like you know the dog barks or porks
um or the cat meows or i talk
right but in fact even me talking like
there's all these
different causal dimensions right so
we've got my larynx like pushing
air up we've got the mouth modulating
the sound the tongues
tongues doing lots of work then the
sound has to move through a medium right
it's the old alien
tagline in space no one can hear you
scream because it's a vacuum
and so the result is um
to talk about any cause of a sound is
already
to to reduce it in a way i mean
obviously
you know if you're talking about
intention like i the intending subject
um produce this thing but not alone and
not
in full command of my own faculties and
in
speaking to you on my screen obviously
in
concert with this whole technical
assemblage so okay
part one sound has all these caught has
multiple causalities
part two is this thing i alluded to
which i actually spend some time
on in chapter three called the ideology
of vocal ability
so the ideology of ability to win
come this term coined by tobin siebers
and it's simply the idea
that people would rather be have
abilities preferable to disability
we would rather people be able rather
than disabled
and like on one level intuitively that
makes sense
allison kaeper says even though i have
these disabilities and don't want to
give them up that doesn't mean i want to
acquire
others right so it's a it's also an
affective relationship so it's a pretty
expanded notion of ideology
but it's this preference for ability
over disability but also this assumption
that a subject is defined by its
abilities i mean and this
could go all the way back to aristotle
saying deaf people
aren't people um
so where was i going with that okay
so the ideology of vocal ability is the
belief
in the voice as the carrier of
subjective intention and agency
and when it's metaphorized like give the
people a voice
or where protesters are taping over
their mouths uh
to like represent that they're being
silenced that is
and that's the ideology of focal ability
at work
right so it's about collapsing this
multi-causal thing of voice
into an intending subject and saying
here's how it always works
so what i'm trying to do in chapters two
and three
is really think through voices
multi-causal
as um contingently cited rather than
organically cited in an intending
subject or an intending body
and as something that might even act in
the world beyond the intentions of an
intending subject right so like nina
kacha durian's talking popcorn
is not siri right no one
is interacting with talking popcorn like
no one's gonna make a movie like
her about talking popcorn right it's not
something that she's not trying to get
you to have an emotional
relationship with this thing in fact uh
you can actually eat the popcorn that
the exhibit is producing
as it well i mean it's not installed
anywhere right now and
during covid probably don't share food
but theoretically one could eat this
popcorn
and uh um so it's a completely different
relationship than like a
personal digital assistant or something
like that and yet it's
also this like rube goldberg machine of
a voice
right there's a there's a digital voice
there's
a decoding of popcorn into morse code
right dots and dashes and pauses and
then the morse code instructs the voice
in speaking and it can be totally heard
in different ways and this happens all
the time
where tone of voice i mean it's the same
with facial
expressions i was on a committee this
winter
um and the the chair kept saying
jonathan you look concerned
and it was just the sun in my eyes so
it's like i had
um i feel pardon the term uh resting
zoom [ __ ] face
and tone of voice is the same kind of
thing right
where it seems to be we treat it as
expressive
and as the result of a person's
command of their abilities but it also
might not and especially along
linguistic contexts um when you're
thinking about accents
um nina i times working on this as well
as um
i'm forgetting your name i just saw talk
of hers on the name will come to me when
i talk about something else
but accent is disability and uh
um i think that this is another example
of like the problem with connecting
voice and intention
so does that answer your question
because if not
i can try again yeah now that conceptual
background is very helpful thank you
thank you
i'm going to take a question from the q
a
from one of our attendees uh who says
thank you jonathan for the
amazing presentation i'm interested in
the metaphorization of disability and
media studies that you mentioned
in your opinion why is the disability
prosthetic
metaphor so sticky persistent persistent
um what kind of advocacy do you see
needed
in order to make academia itself less
oh boy well thank you anonymous attendee
that's a great question
um i want to see it so i'm just clicking
over to answered
while i'm answering it um
why is it so sticky
okay so there's a bunch of answers like
one of the obvious and simple ones in
sanctioned ignorance like
what do people know about and what do
people nod know about
in a given field and what are you
expected to be responsible to
and not and that changes over time i
mean we've been seeing that
uh we've been seeing that change around
indigeneity and around blackness over
the last few years
um in a lot of previously overwhelmingly
white
curricula feminists have been fighting
this
uh battle for generations with cannons
um uh you know of academic literature
and still in communication studies men
are cited way more than women obviously
i've benefited from this
but i will i can still say it's a
problem
um so i you know i'd see
part of it is just plain old sanctioned
ignorance like how many people
in media studies have taken a course on
disability
have thought about it critically if
that's not their area
and i'll give you an anecdote it's not
just media studies
so i uh learned
i so i went to norbert weiner's archives
looking for something at mit at the mit
library
if you go through his papers there's
letter
after letter after letter about
disability and prosthesis
on and on and on because he'd written
because of his
writing on cybernetics and sort of proto
what we call robotics now
and before mara mills who's my
co-author for this uh tuning time book
before she wrote about weiner and
disability
um he was all over history of science
and science
technology studies as his major
historical figure and nobody had written
about it
even though these people had gone to the
archives
and these letters were right there in
the face right
so this is the ideology of ability
discounting disability
even when it's right there in front of
you um
you know and i mean i can go on like
sort of ideologically
i mean then there's the persistence in
media studies in general
in in specific sorry media studies
media studies is a particular interest
in bodies
very often it's the way bodies
are organized into ensembles and
ensembles with
technology and so um
you know and in post-humanism there's a
lot of interest in questions of sort of
augmentation or you could go back to
airways cyborg theory which she herself
now
has sort of questioned in different ways
in the in the later work on animals
and so in those cases um
i think if you're not educated about
ableism prosthesis is a super exciting
metaphor
because it's just extending the body man
and it's modifying the body
and changing the body and those are all
good things right like i
i like insulin pumps i like dorka phones
even though i make fun of them
i like artificial limbs i like
artificial larynxes like
all those things are good um
but prosthetic technology when
understood socially when understood
i think correctly through the lens of
power relations or
in concert with talking about power
relations is not the same thing
as somebody who's not coded as disabled
by their technology
right it's also not the same thing by
other technologies that cause revulsion
like the google glass
slash glasshole phenomenon right which
is a kind of discounting of the wearer
but that's different
than a certain ableist discounting so my
prescription for media studies would be
you know people should learn it's not
that everybody needs to study disability
but people should learn about disability
just
as they should learn um about
indigeneity just
as they should learn about race and
sexuality and gender
and age um as one of the things you
should just know a little bit about
whether you do it or not uh i think that
would be
that would be really good and really
helpful um
as far as making academia itself less
ableist
that's a huge job right so right now
there's this whole problem as campuses
are hoping
to come back in the fall and
many faculty are being asked to go
through what's called biocertification
uh which is essentially i mean it's what
a lot of professors do to their students
right
you missed the test while i need to see
a doctor's note
so now in order to have an excuse for
like
a fairly minor bureaucratic blip this
person has to go
and medicalize themselves
right in order to uh have institutional
legitimacy
right so biocertification is problematic
because of access to health care
because certain illnesses themselves are
stigma stigmatized
um i just taught this great film
called unrest by the filmmaker jen brea
you can find it on vimeo
which is documentary on chronic fatigue
syndrome
that's still uh not very well understood
um and then you know universities are
you know at mcgill my favorite example i
would always take my students to see
this
there's actually a door with an
automatic
door opener right so it's great for
people with wheelchairs to go outside
and then no matter which direction you
go there were stairs
so compliance culture is also a problem
where the like intent of the thing
doesn't work with the bureaucratic
structures and the people
operating within them so it'll take a
lot of work to make academia less
ableist i do a lot of things personally
in my own classrooms like even just
saying
uh in a zoom meeting you know it's okay
to stim it's okay to look around
it's okay to inhabit your body i mean
we're all stuck in our homes anyway
like i've got a unicorn behind me like
clearly
there's a there's there's a lot more
flexibility
uh and hopefully we can hold on to that
as we move back into
collective spaces so thank you for that
question
i'm going to try to be quicker so more
people can ask questions
i'm going to go to nick and then will
in chat and then back to mike so nick
yes thank you vivek and thanks jonathan
for
your talk and for this discussion which
is great i
actually have a question about
prosthesis as it relates to voice
and to telepresence
and teleconference
that isn't directly about disability
it's about how people use different
types of prostheses
to evade surveillance um
and so people do this we know with uh
for instance
face paintings um that might
you know attempt to avoid face
recognition
i'm wondering if people use vocal
prostheses to try to avoid having
the um types of uh
data collection that you discussed
um yeah yeah i totally get where you're
going with this that's a great question
not that i know of however if anyone
would like to
do an art project together trying to get
that working
uh see me after class it's a great idea
i mean
the classic thing is like the pitch
shifter on the voice on the like
no they're interviewing the person with
the shadow you know they're in a shed
like it's a new show and they're in the
shadow and then they're voicing i'm
thinking of a larry anderson
performance where she's got uh she's got
you know this that device that uh you
know transforms
her voice and she's yeah yeah no that's
a
i mean originally it was a vocoder i
don't know what she's used to
i don't know what she's using now and
obviously like it's used to great
aesthetic effect in
um rnb like first vocoders and then auto
tune
so obviously like people do this
but specifically to resist feature
identification
and voice id i think that's a very
interesting question and a pro
very interesting problem
and i think there's all these other
issues around audio surveillance that
are
just now starting to well they've been
getting attention from
sort of critical scholars but the work
is just now starting to come out
in fact i have on my desk there's a
group in australia working on machine
listening
this is called eavesdropping a reader um
and there's a group in germany that's
about to publish a book as well
unfortunately in german
for those of you that don't speak german
fortunately in german for those of you
who only speak german um
but uh but really i think it'd be an
interesting art project
to try to think of something similar to
painting your face
so your voice can't be voice printed and
making it
something that people could easily do in
ambient environments
thanks um so i'll go to a will
who wrote in the chat i'm curious about
the idea that you mentioned
where people unintentionally speak
louder when they can't hear their
own voices or can't
have their own voices fed back into
their ears i may have missed it but
is there a specific name for this
phenomenon
and why do people have a tendency to do
this
uh there probably is in the psychology
literature i haven't bothered to learn
it
[Music]
as for why people do it i mean you know
speaking is a
like ensemble of techniques of the body
like any other
and so i mean i think it has to do with
hearing your own voice in your head
right and when you're projecting it into
a microphone or projecting it into
something else uh when it's not giving
you that same feedback that you get in a
room for instance so
it's worse with headphones on um
although i use the headphones because
they feed my voice back in
um so i mean there's probably some
like sort of naturalistic psychological
explanation for it but i just think of
it as like
this isn't something that people are
skilled for and over time people
do learn to talk more quietly into
mobile phones
like it's not true that everybody that
picks up
a phone call in public now is yelling
into the phone
but it's also true that lots of people
like you know on the bus or whatever
or on the metro it is surprising uh how
much you can hear those
conversations by the way i see in the
chat somebody
typed the name for me it's puja rangan
who's doing
uh voice uh and accent
uh as disability um and she's part she's
got a
she's uh got a collection she's
co-editing with a couple other people
that'll be out
probably well given academic publishing
problem let's give it two years
but she gave a talk recently that might
be online so definitely
uh if you're interested in the politics
of accent
uh her and then nina i time also has a
project going
great let's go to mike and then um
there's
also a question that's been waiting in
the q a
hey i hope it's okay if i keep my camera
off gonna go voice only
uh it's extremely okay mike at first i
was like wow you're sitting so far back
from the camera that's
awesome zoom power move
no no um thank you for the talk i really
love that
um i want to ask what's kind of like the
inverse of next question
i'm curious to hear you talk more about
kind of like the
um potential for a statization
and or and kind of the realm that you're
describing you know one kind of
parallel thing that comes to mind it's
certainly not the same thing you're
talking about but there's this kind of
like famous case of this
pop artist who recently passed away
called sophie who
uh was a trans artist who used pitch
shifting technology
i guess in some sense to sound more
feminine but really the result was to
sound
kind of just otherworldly right so the
idea of you can use the
shifting sound or feminine maybe that's
how it's often used in like
the commercial recording industry but
there's also some other thing that you
can do with it there's kind of a new
realm of possibility that gets opened up
when you sort of
start to engage that technology i don't
know i i guess i'm just kind of curious
especially about this
book that talks about this exhibition
and
i don't know it's kind of a nebulous set
of things that i'm asking but i am just
curious about kind of the role of art
and aesthetics here for sure thanks mike
well
so i would i mean in my own work i've
actually totally parsed out the pitch
shifting
as like for the other book i'm doing
with mauro so the last chapter
he is on auto-tune
and i think i saw kathryn provenzano's
name in the audience
who's writing a whole book on pitch
correction
and owen marshall also is working in
this area um
so just before i go off on it i just
want to
make sure i'm not pretending i'm sorry
generous
so the pitch shifting thing as an
aesthetic practice is
really well established um and the
gendering is interesting because i can
point back
to patent applications in the 1930s
dennis gabor who wrote who created a
sort of analog
time stretching device in the 1940s
talking about pitch shifting is gendered
so it's like
very the high low thing is very much
very much embedded and installed in sort
of western
vocal culture but by the 1970s that
changes
so uh one of the things um
uh we're gonna talk about later later in
the book is uh
um pitch shifting like with eventide
harmonizer
uh parliament funkadelic did this to
create the character knows devoid of
funk
um and you hear it later
in prince you hear it in all sorts of
edm
vocals uh vocal samples and
uh of course also uh very commonly
uh in r b and hip-hop uh people are
using
uh pitch correction very creatively
and i think that's great and now that
many more performers are like
intentionally gender bending than they
were before
um they
this is an even more common practice the
question
for voice print identification so to
connect it back to nick's question
i don't think it's pitch i think it's
stuff like formants
and all the all the stuff that roland
barr would have like bundled under grain
so it's not just pitch but all these
other aspects of the timbre of the voice
and i think there's a lot of potential
there
and musicians and artists have played
with formants and they played with
other aspects of voice there used to be
antares who made um auto-tune also made
a product called
throat which i don't think they make
anymore but it actually had a visual
graphic interface that like a you could
make the throat bigger or smaller and it
would change the sound of the voice
but i'd be interested in being able to
do that in real time in real space
and not just a daw especially in
relationship
to this feature extraction so i think
there's a lot of room for that
all right there's a question in q a um
and and thank you sasha for being
uh very patient this is from sasha
crawford holland i love the talk can you
elaborate on the implications of
mcluhan's prosthesis
amputation metaphors being ableist
yeah thanks sasha well i mean
so mcluhan's your classic mid-century
intellectual that writes in universalist
terms but he was also somebody
uh who didn't really believe in culture
right so mcluhan
uh treats the senses in terms of sense
ratios
he treats uh the human body is like this
one universal thing he doesn't even
really talk seriously about gender or
race and when he does talk about race
it's really really not good
um so it's ableist in the sense that he
assumes that you
human beings all have the same sets of
abilities
and relations to those abilities which
are then sort of
ratioed i don't mean ratio in the
twitter sense
i mean put in ratios to one another
so um the reason why they have the
metaphor is ableist well first
because using disability as a metaphor
when you're not talking about disabled
people
is an ableist act just in the same way
um that uh
when people use um
when people use race or gender uh to
describe
something that is not um
about uh about sort of marginalized
people so i think of like
men using gendered insults designed for
women
for other men for instance that is like
there's no
non-sexist way to do that um also it's
not very creative there's much better
ways to insult men we can
again see me after class if you want to
talk uh
but uh so it's ableist because it is
disability it's
something about us without us right one
of the slogans of the
disability rights movement is nothing
about us without us
and it is
basically speaking of an absent
population using stereotypes
and the imagination of something let me
give you one other example that i think
helps
which is disability simulation which is
still used in medical schools quite
often
so you give students blindfolds and say
well now you know a little bit about
what it's like to be blind
but actually you don't because first of
all you know the blindfolds coming off
and second of all anybody that's been
blind for any amount of time
is going to be way better at navigating
around a room
than the sighted person who just had a
blindfold put on them
so they're going to assume that blind
people are disabled in all these ways
that are actually
not right and so that's
part of the problem with mcluhan's
mcluhan's understanding of amputation
is this very superficial metaphorical
one
if you talk to people who've had things
amputated
they're not going to describe it the way
mcluhan does and they're also probably
not going to describe
their prostheses the way mcloone does i
really
recommend the vivian subchak essay
um on her artificial leg um
the first it's got a long title but i
think the first part is a leg to stand
on
as a good place for thinking about sort
of the metaphoric work of prosthesis
and sort of the problems and
opportunities around that
great thank you so much and we're right
up against
uh 6 30 but there's one informational
um question what was it
um someone wanted to hear more
about you mentioned uh um
[Music]
sorry i'm i'm scrolling all the way back
um
the designer who is
working with you to create the the
alternative
to the yeah and and whether that
designer has
a website um or
yeah yeah yeah let me just make a
network if i type it into the chat
let me just make sure her site is up
because you know how it is with the
digital humanities
ah looks like it's not up at the moment
but i'm gonna give you
i'm gonna give you the name
sorry
so this is the name and
i will also give you the
website although
i can't guarantee that it's up
at the moment let me triple check
it is
great all right thank you so much for
that
and thank you so much for for
um your presentation and for all these
amazing answers to all these amazing
questions thank you all
who participated in that way
and um we
are we will look forward to the book and
um when is it
when is the actual pub date uh december
1st 2021
i think there's some talk of november
but let's say december
okay um so i want to thank you all for
coming
uh it's wonderful to see you while i'm
stuck at home
uh next time we'll like all go out for
dinner and gossip after this because
that's uh
that's where the fun happens not that
this wasn't super fun it's just a whole
other regime of fun
so all right lovely to see you all thank
you so much
thank you zoom wave
thanks take care